every little taste of this Biz made me
want more all those Saturdays I spent at
the liberty and the grand the segregated
theaters of my youth and childhood in
Chattanooga Tennessee imagining hours
Errol Flynn Kirk Douglas team James
cagnes even
John Wayne but uh going home and
recreating those stories with my friends
or just by myself
being all doing the black exploitation
era wishing I was up on that screen and
wondering how the hell do you get in a
movie like that
discovering Peter Sellers Bond the Shaw
Brothers George Lucas I knew I loved it
I just didn't know how to make it happen
and fortunately
when it did in 1990 I was sober
loved and supported by my wife and
daughter
my reason for being and my biggest
critics and my biggest fans
[Applause]